the Mortal Kombat team has recently
updated its classic fighting game
franchise for modern times now that same
team is turning its attention to the DC
Universe with a new game called
injustice gods among us we spoke with
Mortal Kombat creator Edie Boone about
how his team is creating a game that
will make you feel like you're in a
knock-down drag-out fight between two
superheroes well I never really looked
at you know past superhero fighting
games as being flawed I do feel like our
team has always felt like the concept of
a superhero your game the kind of whole
battle of the gods things hasn't really
been represented to the scale that we
always want to do it and that's really
what we're trying to do here is just
really do something that's as big in
scale as you could think of when you
think of somebody as almost infinitely
powerful as Superman or something like
that
environments have have traditionally
been just kind of like a backdrop for
the fighting experience the environment
just is like a pretty painting and
behind you we really wanted to kind of
put tools out there so you know you're
gonna see a parked car on the left side
if you're Superman you can go over to
that parked car pick it up and slam it
on your opponent you can do that as part
of your arsenal in your Batman get throw
explosive batteries at it
and use it from a distance and so it's
that kind of different use of characters
on top of just the normal fighting that
that we have as well as transitions you
know giant big events that transition
you into a new arena with a new palette
of things that you can do that's the
experience we really want to give people
it's similar to Mortal Kombat and that
it's a fighting game and that's probably
the extent of it you know we certainly
did not want to just skin Mortal Kombat
with Batman and Superman and Wonder
Woman and whatnot we really wanted to
create a different experience we're
gonna have blood in the game we're gonna
have damage on the characters damage on
the backgrounds and we're really kind of
replacing gratuitous violence with
over-the-top events so if you think of
Mortal Kombat it's probably more
enclosed more micromanaging events
whereas this game is gigantic huge
events instead of throwing somebody
across the playfield you're throwing
them across another city block you know
and you're doing you know things on a
much bigger massive scale so I think
it's kind of like you can imagine Mortal
Kombat on steroids on steroids